Anything else?
No, all right. I look for a motion a second to approve the remainder
All in favor aye
Opposed all right, I don't 13
B
So just for for clarification
This is the community benefits or the development agreement for the district for the Valley Joe. I just had a couple questions
Is there I know we're at the tail end of the project, but is there discretion?
on some of the language in in the
Community in the development agreement like if we wanted to make a slight modification
Is there precedent for that? Is that that be appropriate?
Well, we have an orange that's already been introduced with specific language. So I think with that at this point
We're just looking for an overall adoption and approval of it. So I think our ability to make any
Substantial changes is very limited. I defer to the city attorney on that, but I believe that's that's correct
We've already had the introduction of the ordinance if there is something
That you would like to see change you could suggest it
And we could discuss it with the developer and come back with an amendment
But as of tonight
You've already given the initial approval is already some initial approval, right?
So the development agreement was initially approved last yes
That was the introduction of the ordinance. Okay. Yeah, cuz I say law requires that the development agreement be approved by an ordinance
Which requires an introduction at one meeting an adoption at another and it doesn't allow for changes and in between
Got it. So if if let's just say for the sake of argument. There was interest in making some changes
We'd have to restart the process. We'd have to do it again. Yeah, does that include the
The entire general plan and and the zoning or is it just a development agreement? Well, it would depend on what you asked for
You know if we're just a change in the development agreement
You'd take the development agreement back through the public hearing process at the Planning Commission and the City Council
Okay, so
So it would have it would go back to the Planning Commission. Yes and the City Council
Got it and you would you would also need to go?
Get the concurrence of of three of your colleagues for that
Initiation of a change in that right? Okay. Yeah, no, I was just I was looking through the the numbers and the community impact numbers
and
I wanted to specifically propose two changes one on the community rehabilitation fee
It's currently at five hundred thousand. That's that's money that would go to local businesses
In in that area, right? And and to benefit local businesses around it says three key areas
eight HVAC roofing and there's like very specific language. I wanted to see if we can expand the language, so it's less restrictive and
Two I wanted to increase the amount. I think 500k is great. It's great benefit
But considering the the hundreds of millions of dollars that are going to be generated in this project
I think it's I'd like to if there's if there's a if my colleagues are amenable like to try to get more
Funding for our residents in this moment
If my colleagues are amenable that would be a separate process
Yeah, and if I could speak to the first of all
I can't really speak to the amount because that's a completely under the discretion of the City Council
But I will say that the examples that were given that you mentioned HVAC and roofie
Those are just examples as part of that rehabilitation program. We would actually staff bring back to the City Council
A proposed program how that would operate specifically what sorts of items would be included
I think those were included just primarily the intent of that word just examples
But there will be an opportunity for the City Council to actually craft that program
In terms of how much would be provided in terms of grants with there be any matching funds and the specific types of improvements
That would be allowed for so you will certainly as a Council have an opportunity to help form that and develop those are just examples
That's correct. Well, then I'll stick to the to the amount
You know, there's there's there's two in particular that I'm concerned about the 500,000 to community rehabilitation
Well, I think that's great. I
I
Like to entertain
Increasing that and also the transitional supportive housing which is money for homelessness is 250,000
I understood that it was closer to 500,000. So if the mr.
Would you like me to respond to that? So there's actually
Two separate items that have to do with dealing with homelessness. There's a transitional living program and that would be for supportive housing
That would be two hundred fifty thousand dollars as you indicated
But there is an additional program and amount
allotted for
For housing for those who are experiencing homelessness and that is just looking at my notes here
That's what we're calling a permanent supportive housing contribution and that is directly tied to the amount of square footage of the of the warehouse
It was approved. So it'd be one dollar per square foot of
Industrial that would go towards that. So we don't have a total of that, but
But it would be driven primarily by how much warehousing would be developed. So it's one dollar per square feet
And is that I know there's there's two areas. There's the 1.5 million square feet and then there's the commercially integrated area
It would that be considered
as well
Under the permanent supportive housing or is that separate? Yeah, that's that would be for the $1 per square foot of building in the light
Industrial district like so I wouldn't it would and and is it accurate to say that's what so it's 1.5 million up to up to okay?
Okay
Any comments?
I just say I absolutely agree with mr. Perez that the examples you cited it says to improve the buildings such as
Those items so when it comes back or council specific approval, you can better define what those
improvements may include
Thank you me personally. I have I don't have
We hash this out in a very long meeting
so unless you hear my colleagues feel differently I
Look for a motion a second a comment. I I
Appreciate
Comments, there's always room for renegotiations this this certainly we don't want another meeting to one o'clock in the morning to hash it out again
but I
If the developer wanted to come out and and offer some additional money, I'd be more we'd be more than happy to allow that to happen
I I think at least we've asked for quite a bit from the developer and and I'm personally okay with where we're at
but if something wants to come back and
Revisits some of these numbers that that's you know, I don't have any problem
Project and I will move to approve the item as
listed I'll look for a second and that is the second reading and adoption of the ordinance correct
Second all in favor. Hi. I am posed
I'm a favor. Okay
4-0. No. 3-0. 3-0.
Hmm? 4-0. I'm sorry.
Oh, you voted in favor of it?
Yeah.
Oh, okay. I'm sorry.
I own 15 public hearing.
Public hearing regarding submission of the 2022-2023 community bill and block grants,
CDBG, consolidated annual performance and evaluation.